hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
today i have a special treat for you
it's a review of a brand new
uh headphone amplifier has a
balanced output and unbalanced output
it's from uh topping it's a a30 pro
is a companion to the dac that i just
recently reviewed
um a lot of these look the same so let
me point out
a couple of things that are special
about this
one thing is uh power supply is built in
which is great you know you don't have a
dongle hanging on the side
there's a ground lift switch which is
unusual
to find on these uh if you have a nasty
ground loop especially on
rca connectors you can play with this
and see if it solves your problem these
things are very hard to get rid of
when you get hit by them so anything can
be good
to have there um these act as both
headphone amplifiers and a desktop
preamp in that you can take the input
and then bring the output out either as
rca outputs or
trs quarter inch uh
so-called headphone jack plugs in the
back also
uh usually these are balanced xlrs but
here we don't have enough room in here
in this medium-sized chassis
so they went with this which is fine and
the pros
may like this better anyway since they
may have those kind of connections
the front is the usual affair on
off switch and whether you have it in
the uh
you have the xlr input or rca output
input in the back remember there are two
inputs
and uh three separate gain switches
low medium and high the low is actually
less than one to one which means that
this
even at max volume it will reduce levels
which is quite useful if you have some
iems that are sensitive
and you can set it to that mode and then
you work in the volume control in the
higher range of it
where the two channels match a lot
better than if you had a lot of gain
you'd be
forced to operate it way down in low
level and
that can cause channel imbalance in
these kinds of amplifiers
anyway as i said there's balanced output
this pentagon and an
xlr output and a regular quarter inch
one new thing from uh topping is this
whole pattern on top tons of ventilation
we should tell you that this thing
probably produces fair amount of power
so with that uh out the way let's take a
look at
objective measurements and listing test
results
let me explain some of these
measurements also as i go through them
um as sort of a tutorial in addition to
the review
the way i test headphone amplifiers is
that i put in what is called unity gain
unity gain means i tell my audio
precision analyzer to generate
x voltage and i then adjust the volume
on the headphone amp to produce exactly
the same output voltage
so in case a balanced devices the
nominal value for balanced input at full
amplitude is 4 volts
so i set the analyzer audio precision
analyzer to 4 volts and then adjust the
volume to get 4 volts and
if you look in here you see that it's
essentially producing four volts
it's an analog controller i can't get
exactly to be that way so all my tests
are this way
it kind of makes it fair because every
headphone amp has a different gain so
it becomes arbitrary then to decide at
what level do you measure the output
so the convention i've said since start
has been that
you know input and output matches if the
device only has unbalanced rca inputs
then i set it to 2 volts because that's
the nominal value for that
this has balanced xlr so i've set it to
4 volts
so that is set to 4 volts it required
medium gain as i mentioned the low gain
requires it anyway
creates an attenuation which i don't
want i want unity gain
and uh using that you can
see here the distortion how many zeros
it has is like
four zeros in here um that's actually a
problem with these distortion numbers
i glazes over all these zeros and it's
hard to remember what they are
so a much better way of looking at this
distortion the tht
plus n distortion plus noise is to
convert that to a decibel value and it's
just a simple math
formula that gives you that and we get a
minus 120
as a number if we converted that to a
decibel
but then if we throw out the minus it
becomes what we call the sign it
so these two right hand side panels are
identical information they're
they're not different measurements
they're the same measurement one
expressed as percentage which is hard to
remember
but the other one is expressed as a
decibel and
120 and the higher the number the better
on this thing if we go up here
the analog output of the amplifier is
captured by the audio precision analyzer
using some fancy math called fourier
transform we can actually look at the
spectrum of frequencies that are in
there uh perfect uh
output this is our one kilohertz tone
this major spike
in the middle this is actually our
desired signal everything else is
undeserved
um we have an undesired second harmonic
and a third harmonic and
fourth and fifth second harmonic is at
-135
remember from my previous videos minus
115 is all we need
anything more than that is gravy so this
distortion is utterly
uh inaudible and definitely not a
concern
at all and uh you know that's the second
harmonic third and fourth are just
way down in noise so
that distortion is much lower than this
cyanide number which tells us that this
noise that
is uh taking us from one minus 135
up to so
put a pin in that let's look at where it
is 120 ranks
i've got this table of all these
amplifiers that i headphone amplifiers
that i've tested
and you can see these slots number three
up here but the difference between
number one and number three is only half
a db or
something like that so it's just
completely in the noise that this is
basically state of the art as as state
of the art can get
and uh ironically right now topping owns
all three top slots in here
uh now from out ability point of view
remember
you know all the way down to 115 these
things are all transparent so
it doesn't mean one is audibly better
than the other one but
means that somebody really sweated the
midnight oil try to squeeze every bit of
noise out of
this noise and distortion out of this
amplifier
if we use that same unity gain setting
and measure the
signal noise ratio we see that the
signal noise ratio is 127 db
so this is like 21 22 bits of dynamic
range
remember cds 16 bits so we're up
22 bits in here we can never get to 24
or even higher than 22 at room
temperature there's just too much
uh noise in electronic circuits to go
beyond that and also my analyzer has
noise
this is actually combined noise from my
analyzer
and the amplifier so
it's really beyond good but i also run a
much more critical test
and a practical test were instead of
having four volts coming out i dialed
the volume all the way down
until i get to just 50 millivolts out so
this tiny voltage
uh out and then i run the same test
naturally noise now has a higher
percentage
so we go from 127 to 94.
94 is basically very much close to 96
which is the best case
dynamic range of 16-bit cd which means
that if you're listening to just
50 millivolt output you're still getting
the full dynamic range of of cd before
you hit the noise floor
this is right now the top
ranking of any amplifier headphone
amplifier that i've tested this is the
most quiet
amplifier you can get uh if you have
very sensitive iems uh in-ear monitors
they can be uh they need just trickle of
power to uh
produce signals so uh the background
noise of the uh
amplifier can indeed become audible a
lot of times people complain and say
well you're showing me inaudible stuff
no no no
when it comes to these little headphones
they're stuck in your ear and
right near your eardrum even slightest
amount of hiss becomes audible so
you really do need something in the 90s
at least
if not 93 to 95 in this graph
to have inaudible his no matter how
sensitive your
iem or headphone might be so
we have superb response in here
um headphone amplifiers well have a
relatively easy job when it comes to
frequency
response and here i measure up to 100
kilohertz so five times higher than
hearing uh bandwidth and we see a tiny
bit of roll off in here for
stability reasons there's feedback in
these things you do at some point want
to roll off the frequency response
otherwise you get into oscillations
at high frequencies and nasty things
happen so every amplifier that's
designed
typically has some filter but that
filter you want it to be high enough
where an
audible range of the 20 kilohertz is
dead flat which is what we have in here
so bandwidth is there this also says
this amplifier is transparent from
frequency response and tonality point of
view
everything from near dc all the way out
beyond
hearing uh threshold is beyond 20
kilohertz
is flat
one of the most important things in
headphone amplifiers
are these power versus distortion and
noise
you could argue if anybody can hear the
distortions that i talked about earlier
or the noise level
but when you push an amplifier at some
point it gets to its limits and once it
gets to its limits nasty things happen
like if you look on the right over here
you see this all sudden distortion
shoots up
all the way to max so clearly this kind
of distortion is audible
and you want to avoid it so we plot
the distortion plus noise versus how
much power
we're producing and want to make sure
the amount of power that we produce is
way beyond what we need
now with headphones is tricky in that
you can get a headphone that may be
12 ohms and you can get a headphone that
maybe a thousand ohms
so these poor little amplifiers have to
handle this wide range of
of impedances and what that means is
that when the impedance is very high
you need voltage to get power um
if the voltage is too low because the
you take the voltage and square it you
divide by resistance
you get the power and if the voltage is
too low
that's the numerator it'll bring your
power down so
for these high impedance slows you need
a lot of voltage
and indeed this amplifier has incredible
amount of voltage
it produces nearly 0.7 watts
to give you an idea a little uh your
phone probably puts out two or three
milliwatts
a headphone dongle may put out 10
milliwatts
this has 700 milliwatts my threshold for
a good amplifier
minimum that i like to see is 100
milliwatts
and this thing is putting out seven
times as much
what's nice about this is that means in
unbalanced mode
it's able to power any headphone you're
gonna throw at it
um a lot of times the power in unbalance
is low and you have to use the balance
connection to get this kind of power
and that requires getting new headphone
cables for your headphone and some
headphones you can't replace the cable
so you can't convert them to balance
here we have incredible amount of power
i don't think i've ever seen
a headphone amplifier that has this much
power and then when we look at down here
as first performance
the first headphone amplifier to break
new ground uh
in distortion and noise was the massdrop
thx triple eight 789.
it's a design that thx came up with and
massdrop or drop.com licensed and at the
time this was revolutionary and you can
see that in this
dash blue line you know fast forward a
year and a half later and look at this
topping 830 pro
in low and medium gains in this green at
the bottom you see
is way quieter than than that
state-of-the-art amplifier that was a
year and a half ago
and if you put it in high gain mode it
then produces a little bit more noise
than a
mass-dropped thx but then it goes way
past it in power to produce this .7
watts before it clips
importantly if you use medium or low
gain
it never clips so if you're listening to
it
at any volume and you hear distortion
it's in your music
it is not in this amplifier
now as i said the impedance range of
headphones varies a lot so
we want to go to the other extreme and
also test low impedance loads
because that emphasizes current we don't
need a lot of voltage
but when we impedance the resistance of
the headphone gets small
then current becomes the dominant and
limiting factor on how many
watts you can induce into the headphones
so
i go from uh 300 ohm load
and i change my load then to that is
connected to the output
to 32 ohms this is 33 but i've changed
it now to 32 ohm
and we see a similar picture again in
low and medium in green and blue
in here performance is just superb no
clipping
and noise is well below
thx reference and then in high gain
again it busts the door open
it produces five and a half watts per
channel simultaneously driven
uh you only see one line in here you
actually they're actually two on top of
each other
and uh that's just incredible come on
get 11 watts of power we're gonna pump
into
a headphone uh
i'll talk about my listen and test later
what happens when you try to do that
um but this is just a ton of power it's
just remarkable
how powerful this little amplifier is
now there is a as i mentioned there is
another
way of connecting headphones which is
instead of having a common ground and
the two leads going to the head to each
headphone you can if you separate the
the ground and so each
cup now has two independent wires you
can power them differentially it's
called balance
that's incorrect just means
differentially which means in theory you
can get four times the power
many times that's needed to get high
amount of power in this case
the power is so high that if you go in
balance mode
you get 800 milliwatts a little bit more
than unbalanced
but you don't need it and the amp is
limiting itself and it won't go any
higher than that
so in this case the balance connection
is a convenience
not a necessity with this unit with many
others
it can be a necessity if you have
inefficient headphones
and then uh for convention i
for the low impedance balance i use 50
ohm load
and uh we get 3.4 watts so
plenty of power in here
um channel balance is a big deal with
headphone amplifiers in that if you have
a very efficient headphone
amplifier i mean headphone you turn the
volume way down here and these are
analog controls with two wipers
on a carbon track and as you get to the
lowest amount
just the accuracy is not there all of a
sudden you may notice a
channel shift from one to the other
which can be pretty annoying
and so i measure for that i uh turn on
the amplifier
put in max volume and i manually turn
the volume control
and the the graph in here by audio
precision analyzer is plotting the
output level so as i turn the gain down
and i'm doing it by hand so it's not
you know precise line this level is
dropping
meanwhile i've also instructed the
analyzer to look at the difference
in the output voltage of the two
channels so we can see if they get out
of whack
at the lowest level as i mentioned all
of a sudden
the the imbalance shoots way up here to
more than 3 db
which is quite audible um but up to
about this point in here
that i've got cursor on um it's less
than 0.5 db
and that's my threshold i don't think
you can hear
a channel shift that's only half a db so
at half a db if i go down here look at
the red line
we've reduced the volume by 50 decibel
which is a ton of attenuation so
in the sample that i have this is
wonderful
this is very accurate you're not going
to notice a channel imbalance
unfortunately these resistors are not
guaranteed to always have great
performance
and some may be worse than this and so
the sample that you get
may not be this good but in this case
it's okay
because you have this low gain mode and
when you're running it in low gain mode
you're operating it in this
wider region where it's much more
accurate so i don't think practically
you're going to have a
problem topic makes a much more
expensive device
that has this r2r ladder relay based
system that is guaranteed to be
accurate so if you really really have to
have 100 accuracy
you're going to need to spend a lot more
money to get that because all those
relays and precision resistors are
not cheap speaking of cost unfortunately
i don't have the cost for this
nor the shipping date i almost always
have this information
but topping send these to me and then
the chinese new year happened and
uh they're off until later in february
so usually they give me a production
equipment i don't accept prototypes or
samples
and so i think once they come back this
will be distributed so i think shipping
date is very quick
um what the cost is i don't know i'm
guessing that it's in this medium
chassis so it'll be medium price there's
the
you know smaller form factor series they
have that's at
you know about two-thirds of this thing
then they have ones that are full size
so i'm thinking this is reasonably
priced
you know we'll find out but my guess is
200 to 300
but we'll have to find out i apologize
for not having that uh
religious but having that information
and just this one time i forgot and by
the time i asked
the tabbing people were out now while i
don't do listening tests for dax
i always do listening tests for
headphone amplifiers
because it's very easy for me to
characterize
at what volume these things fall apart
and get distorted
and i and just like the measurements i
have two special headphones i use for
this testing
the first one i use is a massdrop or
drop.com
dan clark ether cx it's a closed
headphone
i use this because it's has only 25 ohm
output impedance
and it's rather inefficient 25 ohms
is a killer for most uh headphone
amplifiers the ones i recommend
always do well with this by the way
that's my sort of a
litmus test and it had
no trouble uh here um
the a30 pro just drives this like
you know it's not a difficult load
whatsoever
so no problem uh i had it in high gain
mode
and you sort of write it between 10 and
12 o'clock level if you want to listen
loud
and the definition detail resolution
anyway you want to quantify it it's just
exceptional
it's this this amplifier just has no
it is just pass through is it's just
amplifying and doing nothing else your
music
so if you have well recorded music and
i've got a set of reference
uh clips i use for this it's just a
delight to listen to
so that's for low impedance we want to
also then test high impedance and
there's no more
popular uh headphone for high impedance
than
sennheiser hd 650 and
so i always switch to them to this and
if the amplifier has trouble
driving high uh uh
producing voltage this always brings it
out
and boy was this a new experience for me
a lot of people laugh at me because i
crank it up
for the one or two seconds to test an
amplifier just to make sure that
it doesn't get distorted a lot of people
say oh you're going deaf i'm not going
deaf because i only do it for one or two
seconds
with this amplifier i could not go to
max volume
it just was scary scary scary loud i
want to went to about
three o'clock and and it was for just
half a second but i could just tell
you know something was you know like one
just going into my ears for his loudness
and it just was superb superfidelity i
wish you couldn't damage your ears
so you could listen at those crazy
levels but
yes you absolutely can lose your hearing
uh with it with a
uh you know powerful amplifiers like
this so that's where their gain switches
in the front
use them in low and medium gain but the
high gains there because there are piggy
um headphones um when i do my headphone
reviews
i've been starting to collect uh how
sensitive they are and you can see the
range in here
from this nadh p50 only needs 55
millivolts
to produce 94 db spl but then there's
some piggy ones in here like the spare
dynamic dt990
and requires 700 and
we'll see as a test more whether we find
more but some of these are high
impedance headphones
and they are very very inefficient also
and that seems to be the norm you know
these bigger cups and bigger headphones
and
they need uh they're not very efficient
so it is good to have a headphone
amplifier you buy
once and you don't have to replace it
you may go through a bunch of headphones
because you don't like a sound one you
go to another
you want a headphone amplifier that has
both current range
and it also has voltage range which
means you can drive
low impedance headphones and high
impedance headphones
and this this not only does that a
number of other headphone amps
these days do that but also just goes
above and beyond
and so you're not going to have any
trouble with
longevity of your investment let me
finish this with one note
the headphone amplifiers are these days
are dc coupled means there's no
capacitor on the output
they want to allow you to have frequency
response all the way down to dc
basically
and when you do that if something gets
damaged inside this
it can produce dc and it can blow up
your headphones
there are extensive protection circuits
in these both the components they use
and usually externally
to protect against that occasionally
though
with some of the topping products
specifically there's been a couple of
examples of that protection circuit not
being strong enough and damaging a
couple of people's headphones
um they've really gone to town from what
i hear to try to
make this as safe as they can but it's
not something i can test for
um you know you could you know thousands
of people buy
these and then three people find
problems um
so if you're worried about that sort of
thing
wait till somebody else you know others
buy them and
we hear about reliability issues
certainly my testing
i found no problems whatsoever but i
just want to make sure that
you know about this and and uh you don't
jump in and then
come back to play me uh i'm only here to
test the performance of these things
from
uh engineering point of view not from
reliability and even functionality
point of view okay well uh
that's the end of this review got a
little longer than i thought
thanks for stopping by and see you in
the next review bye